le jeudi 19 septembre dans notre
magazine envoyé spécial nous révélions
qu'il existait des disquettes
informatiques contenant des listes
d'entreprises ayant continuer à importer
des farines d'origine bovine
après leur interdiction en raison de la
maladie de la vache folle ces disquettes
étaient stockés dans un service des
douanes toulouse des agriculteurs s'y
sont introduits et les ont emportés
il menace aujourd'hui de représailles
les entreprises mises en cause
christophe la rocca paule iv c'était le
12 septembre dernier dans une enquête
diffusée par envoyé spécial jacques
merlino et patrick des shakers décrivait
comment des importateurs pouvaient
contourner l'embargo sur les farines
animales bovine en provenance de grande
bretagne
le document révélé que les services des
douanes dispose des noms de certains de
ces importateurs une liste non rendu
public jeudi dernier un commando d'une
centaine d'agriculteurs de la
confédération paysanne faisaient
irruption dans les locaux de la
direction nationale des statistiques
douanières à toulouse
ils savent que la liste évoquée par
envoyé spécial se trouve ici et là
réclament tous direct avons des
informations sérieuses venant de vos
services
s'ils veulent ils nous ont confirmé que
cette liste est ici devant le refus du
directeur ils saisiront d'autorité une
vingtaine de disquettes et plusieurs
documents écrits
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs crie
victoire nous avons trouvé une liste
déjà de 50/50 importateurs nous n'avons
pas encore exploité l'ensemble des
disquettes puisque nous avons saisi aux
services de la direction des douanes
une vingtaine de disquettes dont un
certain nombre ont été marqués secret
défense mais nous n'avons pas encore pu
les analyser toutes ces listes josé bové
nous les montre elle désigne
effectivement une cinquantaine
d'entreprises ainsi que des quantités de
farine importée
les services des douanes ont porté
plainte pour vol et ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer sur la teneur de ces
documents tout juste signale-t-on qu'il
s'agit d'une liste globale qui mentionne
des importations légales telles que des
farines de volaille ou des farines à
base de cheval
les agriculteurs vérifieront mais
menacent d'ores et déjà les importateurs
sanctions nous publierons cette liste ne
nous communiquerons à l'ensemble des
médias afin que la chose soit sur la
place publique c'est l'arrêt total de
l'incorporation de ces farines qui est
la seule mesure pour aujourd'hui
copé tout risque les agriculteurs savent
qu'ils sont passibles d'un procès un
procès qu'ils affirment ne pas craindre
car il mettra en évidence les trafics de
farines animales
c'était le 12 septembre dernier dans une
enquête diffusée par envoyé spécial
jacques merino et patrick des shakers
décrivait comment des importateurs
pouvaient contourner l'embargo sur les
farines animales ballin en provenance de
grande bretagne
le document révélait que les services
des douanes dispose des noms de certains
de ces importateurs nos listes nous
rendu public jeudi dernier un commando
d'une centaine d'agriculteurs de la
confédération paysanne
cette irruption dans les locaux de la
direction nationale des statistiques
douanières à toulouse il faible que la
liste est monté par envoyé spécial se
trouve ici et là réclament peu direct
avant des informations sérieuses venant
de vos services
6ème nous ont confirmé que 17 est ici
devant le refus du directeur ils
saisiront d'autorité une vingtaine de
disquettes et plusieurs documents écrits
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs prêts
victoire nous allons trouver une liste
déjà de 50/50 importateurs il ne m'avait
pas encore exploité l'ensemble discret
puisque nous avons saisi nos services de
la direction des douanes
une vingtaine de disques est donc un
certain nombre étaient marqués secret
défense et nous n'avons pas encore pu
les analyser tous ces listes josé bové
nous les montre elle désigne
effectivement une cinquantaine
d'entreprises ainsi que des quantités de
farine importée
les services des douanes ont porté
plainte pour vol et ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer sur la teneur de ces
documents tout jusqu'à signale-t-on
qu'il s'agit d'une liste globale qui
mentionne des importations légales
telles que des farines de volaille ou
des farines à base de cheval
les agriculteurs vérifieront mais
menacent d'ores et déjà les importateurs
champions nous publierons cette liste
nous la communiquerons l'ensemble des
médias afin que la chose soit sur la
place publique
c'est l'arrêt total est la seule mesure
pour aujourd'hui stoppée touristes les
agriculteurs savent qu'ils sont
passibles d'un procès un procès qu'ils
affirment ne pas craindre car ils
mettraient en évidence les principes de
farines animales